dans cette élection on a un choix un
choix entre justin trudeau qui défend
les intérêts des riches investisseurs ou
de voter pour les néo-démocrates qui
règle la crise du logement jack médecine
veut imposer une taxe de 20% aux
acheteurs étrangers qui font
l'acquisition d'une propriété au canada
est ce que c'est vraiment efficace
[Musique]
eh bien non l'impact est plutôt marginal
est de courte durée
à toronto une taxe de 15 % sur l'achat
de propriétés par des étrangers est déjà
en vigueur il y en a aussi une à
vancouver qui devait pour ça les fait
adopter en août 2016 alors que les
ventes de maison diminuait déjà et elle
les a fait baisser encore plus mais
moins d'un an plus tard les faits s'est
estompée le nombre de transactions est
revenue sensiblement au même niveau qu
il aurait été sans la taxe selon une
analyse de la chambre immobilière de la
colombie britannique
l'incidence de la taxe sur les prix est
difficile à évaluer parce que plusieurs
variables entre en ligne de compte mais
une chose est sûre continue de grimper
le prix moyen d'une propriété et 2,1
millions 175 1000 $ à vancouver et 2,1
millions soixante mille dollars à
toronto on va interdire aux
investisseurs étrangers d'acheter des
maisons au canada surtout s'ils n'ont
pas l'intention de vivre au pays la
réalité c'est que les propriétaires
étrangers ne sont pas si nombreux que ça
ils détiennent un peu plus de quatre
pour cent des propriétaires vancouver et
-2 3% à toronto mais pour mettre fin à
la crise il faut souligner que les néo
démocrates proposent aussi la
construction de cinq cent mille
logements sociaux sur dix ans et les
conservateurs eux veulent faciliter la
construction d'un million de logements
en trois ans
[Musique]